hey this is presh to Walker
a hospital has 16 rooms in a 4x4 grid
the rooms are numbered row by row
every room has exactly one patient
the patient in room one wants to meet
all patients and exit from room 16 but
cannot meet another patient twice
how can it be done
I thank Rahul for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
this is a delightful logical puzzle
the first thing to note is that it's
impossible to visit all rooms without
visiting another room twice
you might try to make a path that goes
through every single room exactly once
but you're either going to be missing
rooms or you're going to be visiting
some room twice
It's actually an interesting
mathematical problem to prove that it is
impossible
here's one way you can show that
it uses what's known as a coloring
argument
color the 4x4 Grid in a chess board
pattern so you have alternating squares
of white and black
each time you move between two rooms
you're either going from a black score
to a white square or a white square to a
black Square
so every move includes one white square
and one black Square
to visit 15 other rooms exactly once you
need to make exactly 15 moves
but in an odd number of moves you start
and end on different colors
then we notice that rooms 1 and 16 are
the same color
so it's impossible to make such a path
this same argument shows why it's
impossible for any n by n grid where n
is even it will be impossible to make
such a path going from the upper left
corner to the lower right corner
visiting every single Square exactly
once
but it will be possible for some grids
so just from actually working it out
these grids it will be possible to make
such a path
so how are we supposed to solve the
puzzle because we have a 4x4 grid
you have to look closely at the wording
of the puzzle
it is possible to visit all patients
without visiting another patient twice
so here's the trick
let's say you go to room two
now room one is empty because you were
the only patient in room one
so you can return to room one
since you are the only patient in room
one you're not visiting another patient
twice
so now once you've returned to room one
and you've already visited room two it
will be possible to make a path that
goes through all the other rooms and
meet all the other patients and visit
them exactly once
this is one path you couldn't make
but there are a total of four different
paths you could have made so here's
another path
here is a third path you could have made
and finally here is a fourth path you
could have made
an alternate way to solve the puzzle is
if you visit room five and then return
to room one that will also lead to four
other possible solutions
so that is how you solve this incredible
puzzle
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube
see you next episode of buying your
decisions where we solve The World's
problems one video at a time
foreign